Trascrizione: Gianluca Finocchiaro
Revisore: Carlo Schiatti
(Musica)
"E andare incontro al futuro con la determinazione
non soltanto di credere alle nuove idee
quanto
di fuggire dalle vecchie".
Cecilia Strada: noi cosa facciamo
noi siamo nati nel 1994
per curare le vittime della guerra
delle mine e della povertà.
E da 18 anni andiamo in giro a raccontare
questo che facciamo, che è curare persone.
Raccontiamo quante ne curiamo, dove,
come e perché.
Oggi ho pensato di fare qualcosa di diverso
e di raccontarvi tutto tranne che l'attività di cura.
Di raccontarvi quegli aspetti del nostro lavoro
che sono un po' meno conosciuti
che vanno insieme
e oltre la cura
e di cui, per tanti motivi, non abbiamo mai
tempo di parlare.
Chi sa, ad esempio, che Emergency
distribuisce 80.000 pasti al mese
nei nostri ospedali?
Ai nostri pazienti, ai loro accompagnatori
a famiglie che, fuori dalle mura dell'ospedale
difficilmente mettono insieme il pranzo con la cena.
80.000 pasti al mese sono
un gran lavoro, sono un progetto nel progetto
eppure non riusciamo mai a parlarne.
Così come parliamo molto poco
del nostro lavoro con le cooperative di lavoro in Iraq.
Parliamo poco di come ci piace insegnare a pescare.
Non parliamo quasi mai della nostra squadra di calcio.
Dimensioni che, secondo me,
riescono bene a dare bene l'idea di quanta passione
di quanta creatività serva anche ogni tanto
nel nostro lavoro.
Ad esempio un aspetto di cui non parliamo
assolutamente mai è il rispetto dell'ambiente.
Negli ultimi anni noi abbiamo dedicato
parecchia attenzione al rendere i nostri ospedali
a minimizzare l'impatto ambientale dei nostri ospedali
in giro per il mondo.
Ad esempio con l'uso dei pannelli solari.
Questo è un impianto di 900 metri quadri
di panneli solari nel centro Salam di cardiochirurgia in Sudan.
Oppure dando, ad esempio, attenzione
alla fase di progettazione degli ospedali.
Per cui utilizziamo
facciamo un utilizzo massiccio del verde
esistente, per cui abbiamo costruito ad esempio
quell'ospedale attorno a una foresta di manghi.
Piantiamo nuovi alberi.
Qui siamo in Sudan.
Temperatura media di 45-50 gradi
tutto l'anno.
Per un centro di cardiochirurgia
che ha bisogno di una temperatura
di esercizio delle sale operatorie
sui 23-24 gradi e poco di più negli altri ambienti.
Sarebbe costato un'infinità di anidride carbonica
condizionare questo ospedale e allora
abbiamo cominciato a lavorare prima sull'architettura
sui pacchetti murari, con laterizio pieno
e degli interstizi, delle camere d'aria.
Poi abbiamo ombreggiato l'ospedale
recuperando, come in questo caso,
le tecniche tradizionali di costruzione dei letti
delle donne Sudanesi e abbiamo creato
dei pannelli frangisole
che rivestono l'ospedale.
Abbiamo recuperato le teniche
dei camini di ventilazione tradizionali Iraniani.
Per ridurre il fabbisogno energetico dell'ospedale
filtriamo l'aria con un labirinto sotterraneo
in cui l'aria viene forzata contro diverse paratie.
Poi la puliamo con l'acqua del Nilo
che scorre lì vicino.
Mentre ci dedicavamo
al recupero della tradizione
abbiamo anche lavorato su
soluzioni tecniche innovative.
E' un tick, scusatemi.
Qui, ad esempio, è il reparto di degenza dell'ospedale.
Queste che vedete sono delle intercapedini
nel corridoio, in modo che tutti gli impianti
siano accessibili da questa porta
attraverso il corridoio e tutta la manutenzione
viene fatta senza entrare mai
nella stanza del paziente.
Con, come potete immaginare, un grande vantaggio
sull'igiene delle stanze dei pazienti
in un mondo in cui igiene significa salute.
Trasformare.
Ecco, secondo me questa è una parola
adattissima a TedX.
Trasformare è qualcosa che ci piace fare,
sempre e comunque.
Trasformare, ad esempio, che cosa?
In Sudan avevamo l'esigenza
di trovare alloggi a basso costo
per il personale internazionale impegnato
per molti mesi consecutivi nel centro di cardiochirurgia.
C'erano 97 container abbandonati
nelle vicinanze della zona
dove abbiamo costruito il centro di cardiochirurgia.
I container sono diventati un piccolo villaggio
per le case degli internazionali.
Come potete immaginare ormai sono
tutti rivestiti sopra di pannelli solari
in modo da poter essere raffrescati a pannelli solari.
Questo è un piccolo intervento sugli alloggi del personale.
Questo è un intervento un po' più grande
per cui nel 1999, siamo in Afghanistan del Nord
nella valle del Panshir.
Abbiamo cominciato il nostro intervento
in Afghanistan ampliando, ristrutturando
e convertendo una caserma dell'esercito
in un ospedale da 100 posti letto.
All'epoca era difficilissimo
trovare qualsiasi materiale di costruzione.
La regione era isolata
l'unico modo in cui si poteva entrare
era in elicottero attraverso il Tagikistan
perciò è stato piuttosto complicato
costruire quell'ospedale.
L'unica materia di cui c'era grande abbondanza
nella valle erano i residuati bellici sovietici.
A prima vista questo sembra un carro armato
però se guardi bene quello
è un fantastico tubo per l'acqua.
Abbiamo scoperto che i residuati bellici sovietici
erano una fonte pressoché inesauribile
di materiali da costruzione.
Sicché il nostro personale li ha smontati
e ne ha ricavato putrelle, tubi
e qualsiasi cosa servisse
per costruire l'ospedale che non trovavamo nel paese.
Poi volendo si può essere
un po' più creativi.
Per cui abbiamo preso molto sul serio
il vecchio slogan "mettete dei fiori nei vostri cannoni".
Abbiamo battuto la valle alla ricerca
- anche se non abbiamo dovuto cercare molto -
e questi bossoli sono diventati
delle bellissime fioriere
presso il posto di primo soccorso di Emergency
di Salang, sempre nella valle del Panshir.
I nostri pazienti hanno apprezzato moltissimo.
Giocare è un'altra attività
che prendiamo molto sul serio.
Non potremmo fare altro perché
1 su 3 dei nostri pazienti sono sempre
minori di 14 anni.
Bisogna dedicare una speciale attenzione
per quei pazienti, per esempio
decorando le corsie pediatriche.
Questo che vedete è il centro chirurgico
di Kabul, nella capitale Afgana.
Le pareti sono disegnate da Vauro
che ha disegnato centinaia di piccoli animali.
Ha proprio detto "io voglio disegnare
anche animali piccolissimi, in modo che i bambini
ne scoprano uno nuovo ogni giorno
e possano ogni giorno inventarsi
una nuova storia".
Questo, invece, è il centro chirurgico di Goderich.
In ognuna delle nostre strutture
c'è sempre una sala giochi per bambini
e c'è sempre un maestro di scuola
anche se l'attività principale
più gradita dai bambini rimane
la gara su sedie a rotelle all'interno dell'ospedale.
A volte accompagnata dall'aquilone
di solito semplicemente accompagnata
dalle urla delle infermiere che vengono colpite.
Muoversi è importante.
C'è un principio in medicina:
se il paziente non arriva all'ospedale
devi portare l'ospedale dal paziente.
In Afghanistan questo cosa ha significato, ad esempio?
Ha significato costruire
30 posti di primo soccorso e centri sanitari
che fanno riferimento ai nostri
3 centri chirurgici principali.
E' una necessità nel momento in cui
la popolazione vive distribuita, dispersa
su un territorio dove, peraltro,
non ci sono strade e se anche ci fossero
il principale mezzo di locomozione
per questa popolazione è l'asino.
Il posto di pronto soccorso
che vedevate nella foto sta a 4.000 metri
nella valle del Panshir.
In alcuni casi
si può fare di più.
Si può prendere l'ambulatorio
e metterlo su ruote.
Come, ad esempio, abbiamo fatto in Italia
trasformando due pullmann granturismo
in due ambulatori mobili
attrezzati con due sale visita, un piccola sala d'attesa
per i colloqui e l'anamnesi.
Sono, come si può immaginare, strumenti molto versatili.
Girano per l'Italia dove c'è bisogno
hanno lavorato nell'ultimo anno sopratutto
con i migranti stagionali nel Sud dell'Italia.
Sono due autobus che si chiamano
uno "Questo" l'altro "Quello".
Giusto per.. è stata un'idea del progettista.
dell'autobus, forse per complicarci un po' la vita
dicendo "ma dov'è quello", quello cosa?
Girano per le campagne del Sud Italia
anche se, in realtà, uno dei due autobus
sta da qualche mese
assistendo chi ne ha bisogno a Carpi.
Tra l'altro
un altro principio in medicina dice
"Se il paziente lavora dall'alba al tramonto
in un campo, quando va dal dottore?"
La risposta semplicemente è
"cominci a lavorare al tramonto fino all'alba".
Insegnare a pescare.
Insegnare a pescare è, forse,
la parte più importante delle nostre attività.
Per rendere le strutture autonome
e in grado di camminare con le loro gambe
senza di noi, il nostro personale internazionale
è sempre impegnato nella formazione
a tutti i livelli del personale locale.
Questo è il centro chirurgico di Goderich.
Per darvi un'idea di qualche numero
noi nello scorso anno abbiamo avuto
più di 2000 dipendenti nazionali.
Questo significa un impatto sul paese
davvero notevole, che va molto
al di là dell'attività di cura.
Significa dare continuità salariale
in paesi per lo più poverissimi.
Significa riscatto sociale attraverso la formazione.
Significa anche l'introduzione di buone pratiche
in materia di risorse umane
ad esempio promuovendo la mobilità verticale
del nostro staff all'interno della struttura.
In tutto questo, ovviamente, una particolare attenzione
la mettiamo nella tutela del lavoro femminile
che facciamo lavorare in posizione di responsabilità ovunque
che facciamo lavorare in Afghanistan, dal 1999 ad oggi
initerrottamente in tutte le regioni.
Anche dove sembrava impossibile
la lezione che noi ne abbiamo tratto è
"sembra impossibile, proviamoci! Intanto proviamoci".
E se ci provi
magari c'è pure il rischio che ci riesci
e infatti noi ci siamo riusciti.
E la tutela delle categorie svantaggiate
che, a seconda dei contesti, possono essere
i mutilati in Afghanistan, piuttosto che
gli albini in Africa, piuttosto che
le vedove o i sordomuti
che lavorano grazie ad una collaborazione
con un'associazione locale che tutela le persone sorde.
Abbiamo diverse persone sorde che lavorano con noi
nel centro di cardiochirurgia di Kartum.
Insegnare a pescare, non solo
al nostro staff nazionale, ma anche
ai nostri pazienti o potenziali pazienti.
Noi dedichiamo grande attenzione
al lavoro di prevenzione, di educazione
igenico sanitaria delle famiglie
nei contesti in cui operiamo.
Questo è uno dei nostri
Community Help Promoter
che, armato solo di megafono e la sua bicicletta
girano per il campo profughi di Mayo in Sudan
e tengono regolari lezioni a tutte le famiglie
sulla corretta alimentazione, principi di igiene
su quali sono i segni,
i sintomi delle malattie più gravi
per cui bisogna correre subito in ospedale.
Grazie a queste robine così
e grazie al centro pediatrico che abbiamo
nel campo profughi di Mayo che
è abitato da 500.000 persone
abbiamo dimezzato la mortalità infantile nel campo
nel giro di un anno.
Rispetto. Ecco.
Questa è una cosa di cui raccontiamo pochissimo.
Però mi faceva piacere raccontarvelo
in questo contesto di passione e creatività
perché rispettare la cultura e la sensibilità
dei nostri pazienti, a volte ci ha costretto
a dover cercare delle soluzioni veramente creative.
Noi siamo un'organizzazione laica
però i nostri pazienti hanno, specialmente in un luogo
difficile e delicato e a volte di sofferenza
come un ospedale, la necessita di un luogo di culto.
In un paese come il Sudan, che è multiconfessionale
a maggioranza musulmana, ma con forti presenze
di cristiani e animisti
come si fa a rispondere al bisogno spirituale di tutti
senza offendere nessuno?
La soluzione che abbiamo trovato
è stata questa. Un padiglione di meditazione
con questa struttura.
Qui non si vede, in realtà, attorno
ma è circondata da acqua.
La struttura è orientata verso la Mecca.
Nell'acqua che la circonda ci sono
alcune fontanelle che consentono l'abluzione
dei credenti musulmani.
Non ci sono simboli religiosi visibili.
Però all'interno della struttura,
che è divisa in due parti in modo che
uomini e donne possano pregare separatamente
le fenditure nel soffitto formano
una croce nel cielo.
In ognuna delle due parti
c'è un alberello che è un richiamo
al forte culto animista presente in Sudan.
Gli atei trovano un posto tranquillo
in cui riflettere, quindi il risultato è
che tutti quanti si trovano a pregare
nello stesso posto, che è un risultato
che ci rende abbastanza felici.
Diventare inutili è il nostro obiettivo, da sempre.
Diventare inutili, felicemente inutili
a un livello più ampio, che non ci sia
più bisogno del nostro aiuto.
Mentre cerchiamo di avvicinarci a quell'obiettivo
e a guardare come va il mondo, non siamo
tanto vicini, ne abbiamo di chilometri da fare, Maciste.
Nel frattempo lavoriamo sul diventare inutili
per i nostri pazienti.
L'unico modo è
sviluppare la loro completa autonomia.
Come facciamo, ad esempio, in Iraq.
In Iraq, dal 1998, abbiamo un centro
protesi e riabilitazione.
Costruiamo protesti di gambe e di braccia.
Per inciso, metà delle persone che lavorano con noi
nel centro protesi sono ex pazienti
dei nostri centri chirurgici
che hanno ricevuto le protesti e che adesso
costruiscono le protesi per chi viene dopo di loro.
Dopo la riabilitazione fisica, che può durare
anche diversi mesi, ci siamo posti il problema
della reintegrazione, della riabilitazione sociale.
Noi abbiamo avviato una serie di corsi
di formazione professionale in sartoria
carpenteria leggera
lavorazione del legno
produzione di oggetti artiginali Curdi
in modo che i nostri ex pazienti
potessero imparare un mestiere compatibile
con la loro disabilità.
Alla fine del corso di formazione
che dura 6 mesi
gli aiutiamo ad aprire delle cooperative di lavoro
o delle botteghe artigiane nei loro
villaggi d'origine e li sosteniamo economicamente
fino a quando - di solito sono 6 mesi -
fino a quando non sono completamente
autosufficienti ed autonomi.
Ne abbiamo aperte 275
in questa regione del Kurdistan iracheno.
Il risultato è che tutti i nostri ex pazienti
per cui ormai noi siamo assolutamente inutili
vengono periodicamente a trovarci
a chiedere loro a noi se abbiamo
bisogno di una mano perché, insomma, si sa
si fa fatica a gestire un centro di protesi
e riabilitazione perciò vengono periodicamente
a dirci "se avete bisogno di una mano, chiedetela.
Se avete bisogno di aiuto non fate complimenti
perché siamo sempre disponibili a darvi una mano".
Questo è il risultato straordinario del nostro lavoro.
Vengono a trovarci per offrirci aiuto
oppure anche per fare una partita di pallone
con la nostra squadra di calcio
che è la "Suleimaniya Football Club".
Devo dire che siamo fortissimi.
Più dell'Inter quest'anno.
Forse no, però siamo ....
perché la pace
passa anche attraverso una partita di pallone.
Perché vedere dei ragazzini che erano saltati
su una mina italiana nel 1998
che abbiamo operato nei nostri centri chirurgici
che hanno ricevuto una protesi nel nostro centro protesti
che hanno fatto riabilitazione
e che hanno poi trovato un lavoro
hanno aperto una bottega
si sono sposati e hanno dei figli
che da essere un peso per la famiglia
per tutta la vita
- che è proprio la logica delle mine antiuomo,
creare un esercito di mutilati e invalidi
che pesino sulla comunità per sempre -,
sono diventati quelli che mantengono la famiglia
e che la domenica si fanno pure la partitella di pallone
questo, per me, è il risultato
del nostro lavoro, è quello che fa si che
io sia in quel 20% di fortunati che amano il loro lavoro
e che non vorrebbero cambiarlo
con nient'altro al mondo.
Oltre a tutto a questo, curiamo persone.
Ne abbiamo curate 5 milioni in quasi 18 anni
in 16 paesi.
Oggi stiamo lavorando in 6 paesi
compresa l'Italia.
Avete visto gli ambulatori mobili.
Abbiamo anche un poliambulatorio a Marghera,
vicino Venezia.
Abbiamo un poliambulatorio a Palermo dal 2006.
La novità di questi ultimi due anni
è che visitiamo sempre più cittadini italiani.
Stiamo vedendo
la crisi nelle nostre sale d'attesa.
Ogni giorno
si raccontava prima, ogni giorno abbiamo
tra le 5 e le 10 persone che vengono a chiedere
Italiani, che vengono a chiederci
"mi pagate il ticket? 50 euro per una TAC non li ho".
Oppure "Mi pagate le cure dentistiche?
Perché 1000 euro per il rimborso del materiale
io che sono disoccupato e ticket esente non ce li ho."
Questo, invece, è uno degli aspetti che ti
fanno soffrire nel nostro lavoro.
Abbiamo girato per il mondo per 18 anni
portando assistenza sanitaria di qualità
e completamente gratuita
grazie alla solidarietà dei cittadini italiani
e adesso ci troviamo nel nostro paese
ad assistere i cittadini italiani.
Questo mi fa dire che l'obiettivo di diventare inutile
è sempre più lontano, anzi...
Però nel frattempo noi continuiamo
a fare quello che sappiamo fare: curare le persone
curarle bene e gratis con sopratutto molta passione.
Grazie. (Applauso).